we're not positioned like this we're
actually positioned like this we're
tilted at an angle of 23.5 degrees the
reason why angles are really important
to astronomers is because some level is
all we can measure when you actually go
out and take a picture whenever you take
a photograph what you're actually doing
is recording a whole bunch of angles and
the only way you can turn that into
something more physical like how big
something is is when you know how far
away it is now the symbol for degree is
very simple it's just a little circle
like this and that kind of tells you
where the concept of degrees come from
because of course we're measuring angles
and we can think of angles as just
divisions going around a circle great
sign means to me I in fact we do a lot
of experiments right at the other end of
the scale where we're interested in how
atoms bond together to form molecules
and they were interested in bond angles
so we've got two atoms we're interested
in all of this atoms placed here is a
placed here if there's a twist or a
torsion in that and we use angles and
degrees to attempt to measure that
amount of tilting or twisting now the
choice of 360 is there's nothing special
about that there's nothing fundamental
about a degree this is a symbol this is
a unit that we've invented because it's
fairly convenient if you see something
that looks very small it could be
intrinsically very small and quite
nearby or it could be enormous but on
the other side of the universe so it's
really only when you have that extra
element of knowing how far away it is
that you can start really understanding
the physics of what's going on but the
first thing you actually record when you
actually just take a picture with a
telescope or even with a camera is
you're recording the angular size of a
thing how many degrees does it appear on
the sky so here actually is a work in
progress this is actually a some water
called non-contact atomic force
microscopy experimental results of those
and what we see each blob here is an
individual silicon atom and I guess it's
this one a most most interesting because
what we have here is pairs of atoms we
call those dimers at this surface and
remarkably they have this buckled or
zigzag configuration as you go down the
surface and you can see that here bright
one darker one bright one darker one
bright on the darker one we can
sometimes be familiar with with degrees
in terms of units of latitude and
longitude
so if we take the earth here we've
divided this up into a grid-like system
of lines now there's another very
important angle that comes in off into
all of this which is 23.5 degrees let's
imagine that this this is my earth here
and you can see the stem acts very well
is the North Pole and this is the South
Pole down here so let's imagine that we
are we're on the earth so we're sitting
here in Nottingham the University of
Nottingham and our coordinates are
something like 56 degrees north and one
degree west if this is our equator going
around the middle we're going to be up
here somewhere so let's imagine that
this is us sitting here and not enough
let's imagine this light bulb here is
the Sun now if the axis of the earth
weren't tilted we would be rotating
around like this and that's very simple
to realize you watch the tack and you
realize it has daylight on one side of
the rotation and then it goes into
nighttime as it as it rotates away from
the Sun okay
but in reality and this is due to
however the earth and the solar system
formed we're not positioned like this
we're actually positioned like this it
has lots of implications on for example
one of the implications the reason why
we have seasons and we're tilted at an
angle of 23.5 degrees only does it go
I'm not sure okay so we're actually
spinning something like this and it's
this tilt that gives rise to the seasons
so the seasons don't come about because
we're we were closer and further away
from the Sun seasons arise because of
this tilt when the Earth's axis is
leaning towards the Sun at least in the
northern hemisphere that's when we have
some summer on when we're leaning away
from the Sun that's when we have winter
when the earth is at this position in
its orbit
we've got summertime in the southern
hemisphere and wintertime in the
northern hemisphere so this is about
December when we're over here
it's the opposite so this is July we've
got summer in the north winter in the
south so here the scale unlike megan
scales here we're talking about instead
of parsecs and light-years we're talking
about not just nanometers but actually
down to the picometer scale of hundreds
of picometer scales or ten to the minus
twelve of a meter the angle actually
turns out to be about when these in
these buckle diamonds turns out to be
about 18 degrees okay so one neat
coincidence about the fact that our axis
is tilted by exactly or precisely 23.5
degrees is that it means that we're
always our north our North Pole is
always pointing in one particular
direction because of the earth rotating
the effect of that when you're sitting
on the others it makes it look like the
skies rotating looks like the sky is
going around the other way and so one of
the things that astronomers have to
worry about is where in the sky
something is relative to that axis about
which everything is rotating so the pole
star at the moment is sort of pretty
much right on that axis so the pole star
doesn't move very much or doesn't appear
to move very much because of the Earth's
rotation okay so let's let's imagine
that this room is full of stars and
they're much much further away from from
us than the Sun is and as we sit here on
our earth and as the Earth turns over
the course of the night we'll see that
those stars appear to move just like the
Sun appears to move as we rotate around
now our North Pole on our Apple actually
points to one particular star so let's
imagine that that motion detector up
there is the star I'm talking about this
is what we call the North Star or the
pole star and there's absolutely nothing
special about this star it's a
completely ordinary star it can be kind
of hard to find sometimes if you don't
know what you're looking for but we see
it as being special because of all the
stars in the sky it's the one that
doesn't appear to move at least if
you're looking for the northern
hemisphere
what-oh simply because that's the
direction that that our North Pole is
pointing in so as we rotate around all
these other stars are going to appear to
be moving but that one is going to be
staying in the same spot pole star is
not absolutely exactly on the axis of
the earth on the on the extensions of
the Earth's axis into the sky
so although the earth rotates about an
axis that
points almost at the Polestar it's not
exactly at the Polestar and of course
the other thing that's going on is the
Earth's axis is itself processing over
time so over tens of thousands of years
where the North Pole is actually moves
so what's the pole star now in 10,000
years time won't be the pole star
anymore